nene leakes you put her in a room or in
this case in a zoom with a bunch of
other housewives and drama ensues I
don't see Nene anymore the ladies were
deep into the first two parts of their
three-part reunion episode shot from
home when Nene gave us some classic
housewives walk-offs quarantine style
why why not everybody is firing at me
consistently it's not fair you wouldn't
want to be ganged up on 4 & 5 people
shooting at you at the same time it's
not cool they have done it season after
season after season and I'm over it
being in the comfort of your own home
you feel like you can say and do
whatever you want is there anything you
want to say to the other women no okay
guys sunday is part three Nene doesn't
expect to see yourself on air
but is the og peach gone for good every
year I don't know what I'm doing so will
I walk away I just don't know you have
to treat me like this is the house I
built I was the first one in this house
and everybody else feel threatened by my
presence but at the top of the damn
mountain will be Kenya a shady bad skin
bad attitude black hearted so if I lived
in what they gonna do this is me just
talking to you you ain't leaving I don't
think you're leaving because I think
they pay you no matter what sometimes oh
my name you still gotta be happy
next up for Nene she and hubby Gregg
just bought a local bar she first one
comes to get my bar and have some drinks
okay then I'll tell you all about that
and as for that masked singer reveal of
co-star and frenemy kandi Nene knew long
before the finale I know my hand
gestures I know my height I know she was
out in LA I know it's
[Music]